-Our next guest is a very
funny comedian and host
of the podcast "Entry Leve
with Brooks Wheelan."
New episodes are released
every Monday.
Please welcome back to the sho
my friend Brooks Wheelan.
How are you, Brooks?
-Hey. I'm perfect.
-It's so wonderful to see you.
We were supposed to see yo
earlier this month.
You were booked,
as well as Ted Danson,
on January 6th.
I don't need to
tell everyone that's the day
that the Capitol was stormed
we agreed to reschedule you.
In place of you, we booked a
Killer Mike to talk about
the events of the day
and his activism.
You agreed with that decision.
-Yeah, I didn't think it was a
poor decision not to have me
comment on a bunch of Al Bundy
taking over the Capitol.
So I was, like,
"Let's have Killer Mike
maybe talk about this
for a second.
-I was texting with some
of our mutual friends.
Tim Robinson was one of them
I was texting with John Oliver
as well and I was saying
I half wanted to keep you on
because I thought there migh
be a chance that you
hadn't heard
about the Capitol riots yet.
-And that's exactly
what happened.
I was texting with John
because he's the best,
and I told him that I wasn't
watching the news on purpose
that day because I love doin
your show and it's so fun.
I wanted to be in a positive
mood, and the news makes m
in a terrible mood,
so I was just like
I just won't watch.
And we recorded this at noon
L.A. time.
I get an e-mail, "Hey, we're
going to push it
due to the Capitol events.
And I was, like, "I guess we
should probably check that out
And I went to, like, CNN,
you know?
I was like, "Okay, it look
pretty legit."
And then I decided let's g
to Fox News to see
if they're even commenting
and they were,
and that's the scariest thin
is when Fox News is also like,
"It's pretty bad."
[ Laughter ]
-You tweeted that you agre
with the decision to put
Killer Mike on the show,
and this was really exciting
Killer Mike now following you,
so you got a follow from
Killer Mike
plus love and respect.
The whole day
was a pretty good outcome.
-Best day of my life,
January 6, 2021.
I'm the new LP.
That's pretty exciting.
You know, our music might
want be as good anymore,
but I'm having fun.
-I mean, re-scheduling you
is always bittersweet,
but it was even more bittersweet
that no matter what happened
on the 6th, you weren't goin
to be here in person.
When you were here in 2015
in person,
which is actual
your twitter photo,
I am very honored to be
your twitter photo.
-You were my boss, man.
You got me hired at "SNL."
You've really helped my career
a lot, and any time you ge
to drink Keystone Lights
on national television
with, you know,
someone you respect,
that's a Twitter bio.
I don't know what to tell you.
-You did bring Keystone Lights
I really --
I had forgotten this.
I had a Keystone Light
and then you had one
and then you had a backup
Keystone in your pocket.
-There's two in there.
I got have one in
the other guy, too.
-Did you bring a Keystone Ligh
so we can continue
the tradition?
-I did, and I also want to say
this is what would have been
funny if we did it January 6th
We would have been
doing this bit,
drinking Keystone Lights
during an insurrection,
and really Killer Mike
saved the day.
-I have -- I got the --
So, you've got the whole pack.
That's great.
-Here's the problem
with living on the West coast.
This is not a West coast beer.
I had to go to five
grocery stores.
-What coast beer is it?
I guess it's an East coast
-It's Pennsylvania.
-Yeah.
It's Pennsylvania.
Of course, Keystone,
and I should --
I hope you know this, Brooks
This is my first Keystone sinc
last one we had together.
-Mine, too.
You did this to me.
This is your bit.
-Cheers, buddy.
-Cheers, Seth.
-Hmm.
That's exactly
how I remembered it.
-Yep. Hot.
I love a hot Keystone.
-Keystone right now is balancing
whether they're going to use
that photo of you
because they're, like,
free advertising,
but the face you made,
they might be on the fence
-No, true story.
Last time I did it,
another friend of ours,
Cecily Strong hit me up
for my address.
Keystone Light sent me three
30 packs to my house in L.A.
Ruined my refrigerator
for about two months,
but I appreciate it.
-Alright.
-Let's get them up
one more time to make sure
You get a couple more 30 packs
There you go.
Good. Get the label out.
Great.
[ Laughter ]
Perfect.
-Perfect.
That's called being funny
on key.
-They're going to be real
happy with that.
Brooks, you talked about
Keystone giving you free stuff
You actually got some
free stuff from Asics,
the running shoe brand.
This is such a perfect
Brooks story.
You decided in the middle
of a pandemic
to run a marathon,
but not --
The first marathon
you ran,
well, just talk us through
how it came about.
-Here's how it happened
real quick.
Okay, drunk with my friend
adds up.
I said I don't think
marathons are hard.
He said that can't be true
I said I'll run one
tomorrow for $500.
He said deal. This is maybe at
1:00 in the morning.
So at noon,
I go to run my marathon.
-So, this was just,
you were going to run
for 26 miles using a running
app.
-26.2 miles, yeah,
using Runkeeper.
I do -- before we left,
he decided I need to run i
under the average,
which I did not sign up for.
I didn't think I could do.
Then we looked it up.
Oprah runs the average.
I felt like I could beat Oprah
No offense to Oprah.
I just feel like
I should be faster than her.
So I go and I do it.
I do it in 4 hours
and 16 minutes,
and it's not that hard,
and I brag about it
and I say marathons aren't hard,
but cut to a few days later,
I destroyed my knee.
I got iliotibial band syndrome
and I couldn't walk
for about six months.
So they are hard,
and I'm a liar.
Then Asics hits me up to say
"Hey, what if you trained
correctly, psychopath,
and we'll see how you
do that way."
And I did it.
I ran, trained appropriately
for three months
with Asics and went to run
another marathon.
This is a month ago,
and I was going pretty fast,
trying to run a 3 hour
and 30-minute marathon.
And I was trying to parlay
into another sponsorship,
so at the half marathon mark
I slammed a 20-ounce
Mountain Dew to say Mountain Dew
is good for you
and it will help you
run marathons,
and my body seized up
immediately.
[ Laughter ]
I had to lay down for abou
20 minutes,
and I ran much slower
than my first marathon time,
and Asics wasn't stoked,
but I did get
some free Mountain Dew stuff
-Alright.
So, you are kind of --
you're kind of piggy backing
one of these into the next
which is classic Brooks style.
-[ Laughs ] Yeah.
Hillbilly juice and nice shoes
[ Laughter ]
-So, your first half marathon,
the first half before you ha
the Mountain Dew, you were
actually on
a pretty good pace, right?
-I was running a three hou
and 15-minute pace,
which is shockingly fast for me.
-That's shockingly fast
for most people.
That's a very fast pace.
-Yeah.
So it's just proof
that Mountain Dew --
Mountain Dew will derail
anything you have going.
[ Laughter ]
-Now we were lucky enough,
again, like better days
and thank goodness
at the timing of it.
When I was going out
and touring,
getting ready
for my stand-up special,
you were on the road with me
and it was such a delight.
It was such fun hangout times,
and you actually got to meet
and sort of see up close
what my dad was like.
-Yes. Okay.
So, that's the other thing
Like, you ever get those
on your phones, like,
"Hey, remember this last yea
at this time?"
For me, this summer,
it was remember last year.
It was July 2019.
It was you and me
and Shoemaker and your brother
having the best time
of our lives going
to your Netflix taping
and then Lonely Island
specials.
And for me, the best part
of touring with Seth Meyer
is seeing Larry Meyers lay
into Seth Meyers in the mornin
about what jokes
didn't work the night before
because you texted me.
I'm upstairs in the hotel room
in Pittsburgh and you're like,
"Hey, we're having breakfast
if you want to come down."
Of course, that sounds awesome
I didn't know I was coming dow
into a think tank
between Seth and Larry
about what you should do
for your Netflix special,
and it was great because
I never see anybody
give you guff, you know?
You're Seth Meyers
and you're my old boss,
so your dad
was just telling you.
Do you remember your
football helmet joke?
-Yeah.
-Okay.
So, you liked your
football helmet joke,
I thought it was okay,
Larry Meyers goes,
"Not funny."
[ Laughter ]
So, I start laughing really hard
because I'm seeing my friend
Seth, get yelled at by his dad
and then your dad goes,
"I've got notes for you, too."
And he did.
[ Laughter ]
He told me how much more
comfortable I looked second set,
and he didn't think I should
open with this joke,
and he was right.
-That's the bummer.
-Yeah.
Like, you want to be able to
say, "You don't know, Dad.
And you take his notes and
you're up on stage saying like
"This feels
a lot better tonight."
-Yeah, Larry Meyers knows
what he's talking about.
-Well, He'll be,
I don't need to tell you,
very happy to hear that.
[ Laughter ]
Brooks, it is always
a full delight.
Here's a Keystone toast to you
and I hope to see you
in person again soon, buddy.
-Dude, I can't wait.
You're the best, Seth.
Thanks.
-You're the best, Brooks.
New episode of "Entry Leve
with brooks Wheelan"
are available
on Mondays wherever
you listen to your podcasts.